you
hi everyone is Gerry let's have a look
at a game for
eleven of the top
championship season 14 Super Final so
this is the game between Lila Chazz zero
on the white end and stockfish ten these
are the two that earned the right to
compete in this final matchup this 100
game encounter and well at the time of
this recording there about halfway
through that match and Lila is just
barely ahead winning seven games to
stockfish as six the rest of those games
being drawn of course and well certainly
an interesting moment for chess are we
going to have Lila ai Lila chess is zero
finally beat the world's very best chess
engine it remains to be seen the game
I'm about to share with you is where
Lila breaks stockfish 10 earns that
first full point and it comes out of an
opening that I think is ideal for Lila
so let's see what that opening is why I
think it's ideal and what exactly about
this game I found instructive or most
instructive so opening wise we have the
French defense tarush with Knight to d2
knight c6 denotes the gwee marred
variation and this position right here
is where game 11 began ideal for Lila I
feel because it is strategic many
instances of fixed pawns a fixed center
at the moment and I think you know we
start to enter a much more strategic
battle and I think that suits Lila's
style more so than stockfish now the
approach in well let me say this
round 12 had the same position with
reverse colors so that's how they do it
the openings are already mapped out
what openings will be played in those
100 games and each side is gonna have a
shot with you know each color from this
position round twelve Leela as black
played Bishop e7 and castled Kings side
in this game here as we will see
stockfish says no way
I'm not castling kingside I'm gonna take
a hike and go a queen side and it really
is Ike there's a lot of black king moves
in this game so in this one we have b6
c3 it's already anticipating c5 and
Knight to e7 now let me just let me
pause for a moment I'm gonna throw it an
early pop quiz your way that doesn't
have any one answer to it now there's no
correct answer here but I just kind of
wanna you know I want to I want you to
benefit from this game I benefited from
it I want you to benefit from it so I'm
gonna share how I see the board and the
organization of the white pieces in this
game is was a very nice iOpener for me
so what is it about this position what
one white piece or pawn sticks out to
you more so than any other feel free to
pause the video think about it for a
little bit and see what you come up with
okay anyhow I'm just going to share how
I see this position what sticks out to
me the pawn on e5 with some attention to
this pawn on e5 it'll help us to
understand many of the reasons behind
not only the white moves but black moves
this is a great strength for white white
has some space on the Kings side this
takes away a favorite square by one of
the Knights f6 is under control by white
black constantly has to work around this
guy on e5 now II five the the pawn on e5
would its strengths would be enhanced if
it had the option to move if it could go
to e6
doesn't have that option but white is
going to take some steps to try and make
that be the case how can we get it so
that maybe the e6 pawn is not there you
have to put some pressure on it let's
see how white approaches this H 4 C 5 H
5 this is something that must capture
blacks attention white is threatening to
play h6 make the g7 pawn flinch and once
the g7 pawn flinches moves or captures
the e5 pawn becomes that much more
powerful it then controls a hole in the
black position so black says no way can
have that continuing we have a knight h4
so again what is the point behind Knight
to h4 while this is freeing the F pawn
to one day advance to the f5 Square to
have an influence on e6 so that the e5
pawn can become that much more effective
moreover Knight h4 move is not just
paving the way for the F pawn to advance
but also opens up the diagonal for the
Queen
g4 nearby black shuts things down on the
Queen side know if there was ever a
capture on d4 white without question is
capturing with upon keeping the knight
boxed out keeping 'if I've secured it's
the main point we don't have that things
are shut down on the Queen side some
Knight - d - this is where black plays
with b5 organizing the pieces now first
Queen g4 clean right next to the night
Queen night both facilitating one day
and f5 pawn break a5 seems to be
prepping B for Bishop to e2 there isn't
another square for that guy
a four so this definitely caught my
attention you know when you see a five
you're thinking well this is to support
a B for advanced I believe the primary
idea behind a four in this position is
to try and lock down the Queen side so
that the black King can have a safe
haven on the a5 square now a four is
threatening to play a three
I think this would cause a disruption on
the Queen side for the white pawns so
White's reply here is to play a three
and with this we have basically files a
through e locked up really an
environment I think that Lila who is
going to do very well with nine games
out of ten like I wrote I really think
the the win winning percentage is very
high for Lila in this within this
structure so doing something else so
doing something other than a four here
by black if B for white can follow just
throwing a couple moves out there
castles f4 and white could look forward
to a very quick f5 break you know white
is ahead development wise the pieces
that black has developed ok black has
made a couple many pawn moves in just a
couple Knight moves it looks like
alright and they're not the greatest
nights in the world second ranked
Knights f5 is hitting very fast so the
idea here by stockfish Tennant appears
lock down the Queen side okay after a
three we have regrouping there's a big
gap in White's position that gap b3
that's where the knight is heading it's
see 6a v b3 nearby so let's see how
white copes with a night on b3 you have
to try and work
around it or do you capture it what do
you do let's find out
first f4 Knight f1 so another
instructive moment where exactly would
you like to have this Knight you can see
plenty of players go forward with Knight
to f3 but from f3 it is observing white
pawns that do not need support they're
already well supported by pawns this
Knight should look to take a more
aggressive approach and put pressure on
black pawns so it pivots on f1 Knight a5
Bishop e3 Knight b3 and rook to d1 now
what black piece is blacks best piece in
this position any thoughts on that feel
free to pause the video okay I'm just
gonna share my thoughts I don't know if
you think it's the night on b3 I
actually don't know if that Knight is a
best piece it might be one of the
black's worst pieces believe it or not
maybe I'm going a little too crazy with
that comment but it's a knight that sits
very well that's true sure you can't
can't scared away but it's kind of just
in a quadrant that is mmm it's in a
relevant section of the board the action
there's not going to be anything
happening in this area and it's
difficult to see how black coordinates
with that Knight to cause any chaos for
white on the Queen side
it's a knight that is that sits well but
is just conveniently under control and
in a way I feel out of play
okay from here black takes a high
and we have a lot of just feels like
shuffling moves by black in this game
meanwhile white is making some slow
steady progress on the side of the board
where white has space the Kings side so
Bishop to f2 and Knight - III sir ting
pressure on something of blacks d5 pawn
King to b7 Queen to h3 already eyeing up
g4 or maybe even Bishop to g4 with f5
alright look at look how both Knights
are positioned to facilitate this f5
move maybe maybe here or here is being
lined up I think I think the idea here
is if you can get in the f5 break and
keep this this Hart back home I was
referred to this middle pawn of you know
the fgh pawns as the heart keep that
pawn around as some shelter for the King
I think that's a good idea
black reacts at this stage doesn't wait
for white to just kind of slowly build
up lashes out with g5 there isn't really
a great constructive plan for black you
know you could make as many King moves
rook moves bishop moves knight moves are
they really improvements for black it's
tough to see what black does to improve
the position g5 on this move 21h takes
GM sun on recaptures and white does in
fact play with the g4 in this one King a
six-night to g2 also something to note
here is if instead of king a6 if black
plays g5 of course we do not take
because this is going to be a problem
what would you do and reply to g5 you
being head of the night and prepared to
recapture on f4 and now that this pawn
has moved the f5 doesn't have as much
control so white is already
much closer to advancing f5 we see this
shot soon enough but first in this game
it's King to a six-night to G to rook to
g8 and Bishop to Bishop to f3 so we're
starting to see some pressure on d5 at
some point there can be some tactic as
soon as you knock out you know the legs
of this d5 point influence a six this
can collapse
so from here King to a five now it seems
like the coziest home for the King and I
did get to watch a good portion of this
game live and I recall around this point
thinking to myself well that seems like
probably the best Square for the black
King and I also started thinking about
well well where would maybe be a best
Square for the white king and I want it
I want to share where my head was at
with that question because this is where
I feel I I grew some as a player I
thought to myself the white king if
white wanted to be extra cozy with the
king the king would take a hike and go
to a2 and it may be true that the King
is tucked in very well on a2 but as
things become a bit simplified as we
will see in this game the King can
actually take a much more aggressive
approach and be a contributor on the
King side and well if the King is all
the way over here on a - it's that much
longer of a hike to go towards the Kings
side you know this quadrant over here
anyhow from here Bishop to h4
interesting journey this Bishop has
taken this keep in mind is the bad
Bishop what is white doing activating
the bad bishop it is now officially stay
outside of the pawn chain shot down for
the moment g5 returns this is nearby
black takes that pawn out
Knight recaptures and look how beautiful
this position is if you want to kind of
assess any one position something you
could always look to is whose knights
are doing better
alright look at this key portion of the
board sixteen squares the ideal
environment for knights white knights
are in the box these guys are out and
look at the beautiful coordination as
well that the miners have on d5 you can
very easily see some tactical
opportunity on this point from here rook
a7 Bishop h4 o also when g5 was in as
soon as that move was in f6 is a hole so
it's being eyed up right now by the
bishop right here we have Bishop d7
castles so no King hiked over here do a
two nothing a long-term like that
no no great King walks to the Queen side
castles on board Queen e7 rook F to h5
is met with g5 so this is a giving up a
hole here on f5 that's something black
could really go in for because there is
a capture and then d5 will fall so the
focus here is f6 Knight g6 pair of
Knights are exchanged first piece
exchanged and white is not giving up on
the up six squared an e5 is strong g5 is
strong both allowing a piece to pivot
there even if a bishop is around a
capture rook
doesn't have to budge because there's
always a capture with the EEP on this
guy's backwards and white would have to
connected passed pawns that are just a
couple two or three ranks from queening
it's a tremendous position for white
completely in control
Bishop c8 queen g3 some reorganizing
here the white pieces are improving and
it's just a lot of shuffling
unfortunately for black and a knight
again looks pretty on paper you know but
what is it doing it's completely under
control by the rook not a great
inconvenience at all to team white where
is the action the Kings side this guy
here's out of play Bishop to g7 the rook
doesn't have to budge King 2h - moving
forward getting off of G file no pins
rook f7 suppose the rook is captured
this is tremendous connected pawns
beautiful bishops and a huge square on
the e5 and a knight again doing nothing
okay we don't have that rook f7 Knight
g2 is this not the second time we have a
fiend cut out night in this one eise X
is target again trying to get this guy
to move get rid of the e6 pawn Knight f4
nearby King a6
you cannot take twice on f6 in this
position so for example it takes and
then takes of course you can't take the
rook because the Queen would fall but
the way out would be to insert a check
and only then take the rook so blacks
last move King a6 is maybe now
threatening to take twice because there
isn't this resource to move the Queen
off of the G file with check Queen e3
and this one
King a seven-night f4 and again if ever
a capture like this
II take sin it's tremendous the night
look how beautiful it is pressure on the
pawns facilitating g6 pressure on upon
it's a wonderful position for wipe can
continually improve rook g1 King b8 pawn
advances and a little bit more
reorganization here at this point we
have a a capture on e6 finally if
something other than that let's say King
here white can continue with Queen f3
and take the h5 pawn that's a way
forward for white but in this one we
have rook b7 finally II 6 collapses this
pawn is now a passer along with the pawn
on g6 it's true this pawn is passed but
yeah it's not even really felt it's not
going anywhere with the bishop on h4 and
in a way this white is probably happy to
have the pawn on h5 there's no no
problems that the white king experience
is so with this sequence simplifying a
bit more white is picking up some
material and yeah is up upon and
continues to be in the driver's seat so
let's see how this one finishes up
basically the knight tries to get
involved cos upon and here we go if the
King was all the way over here on a2
wouldn't be around to help advance on
the Kings side the white King actually
looks to help out on the King side
SunGard some squares offer Queen
exchange eventually and if the Queen's
are off this is super easy this move
here is just out of desperation
basically that's not the right term but
just kind of maybe threatening at some
stage to play a3 and then after capture
rook takes c3 but white will always be
there to secure that point
so the King has come quite a ways can
rely upon these dark squares huge pawn
chain here for teamwipe Queen exchange
is avoided this is defended and we don't
go to many more moves and other pawn
falls and we don't go much further here
the final position with this game is
right here
after King to b7 this one goes no
further
the game ends in favor of team white now
if this one did continue I think a
pretty clean way to see how that would
be the case is offering a rook exchange
and let's just say a king move is on
board we could get the rooks off we can
offer a queen exchange and if let's say
Bishop e6 you could already put them up
promote right away in the event of a
Queen takes Queen there's checks and
more checks or checks it's already--as
main 11 and if something like let's say
B 6 and this Queen f5 move let's say the
Queen moves like this looking you get
involved like that there's Bishop g5 and
really no need to go any further we have
the idea of Queen f6 Queen to f8 going
to c5 you know the Queen Bishop and even
this pawn is going to cause some problem
to the black King there are no perpetual
x' here for black and it's the engine
I'm looking at right now I'm using stock
fish 10 it's already plus 16 so it's
just completely gone here for team black
but it ended here you could simplify
further with rook to h8 and yeah no good
progress here for team black game ends
after 76 moves again the instructional
moment for me was that little regrouping
on the Kings side racing that pawn all
the way up to h5 tucking the knight in
right behind and then getting the Queen
on g4 and then you know getting the
bishop involved putting the knight on
the e3 square exerting pressure on a
black pawn now staring at your own pawns
that's setup there is very instructional
and well that's one of the main reasons
why I'm sharing this particular game
with you I found instructive and well
hopefully you did as well anyhow as
usual feel free to leave any feedback to
this video in the comment section below
hope you enjoyed it and again maybe took
something away from it that's all for
now take care bye
you